♪
>> Shannon: FINALLY TONIGHT,
"NOTABLE QUOTABLES."
>> YOU WANT AN EMERGENCY?
WE HAVE AN EMERGENCY.
[SIREN]
>> SOME REALLY BIG THINGS
HAPPENED TO OTTO.
HE TELLS ME DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT, AND I WILL TAKE
HIM AT HIS WORD.
>> STRONG NEW REACTION
COMING IN FROM THE REACTION
OF OTTO WARMBIER CALLING OUT
KIM JONG UN OVER THEIR SON'S
DEATH.
>> THIS IS NONSENSE.
YOU GUYS NO IT.
I KNOW IT.
>> TALKING IS DEFINITELY
BETTER THAN FIGHTING.
>> HEARINGS ARE NOT FOR
ACTION.
>> WHEN YOU CALL DONALD
TRUMP A CHEAT IN YOUR OPEN
TESTIMONY, WHAT WOULD YOU
CALL YOURSELF?
>> A FOOL.
IF THERE.
>> YOU ARE A PATHOLOGICAL
LIAR.
>> I'M NOT CALLING HIM A
BUNNY BAWLER BUT HE IS A
LITTLE UNBALANCED.
>> PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
HAS MORE STORIES THAN HARRY
POTTER.
>> THE RELATIONSHIP WAS VERY
WARM AND WHEN WE WALKED AWAY
IT WAS A VERY FRIENDLY WALK.
I WILL LET THE ANKLE BITERS
BITE OUR ANKLE.
>> A LADY CAME IN AND GIVE
US -- I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I
WAS GOING TO DO.
>> POLITICS STOPS AT THE
WATER'S EDGE.
>> GOVERNOR NEWSOM DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
>> THE REF MADE A BAD CALL.
>> OPPOSITION PARTY IS
SWELLING AND FLAILING.